when a man can't sustain an erection a
search for explanations begins in our
culture most of these explanations tend
to be punitive humiliating and
catastrophic for both parties do you
even love me anymore is that why you
couldn't get it up
are you not attracted to me
I've been do some research reading some
Freud and something happened in your
childhood I don't know it's your mom's
fault but you're not right you're really
not right John have you been taking your
vitamins hmm I'll go to the chemist
we'll get you some more I think you must
be gay all the signs are there the
guilty men for their part are often
hopeless at coming up with any better
explanations you're very attractive and
I love you and it just it doesn't that's
not how it works and just let's I can't
just
you know it's just been a really tough
time at work you know with the
presentation and what if it's you have
you thought about that
have you considered that that maybe it's
you it's something that you're doing
you're putting me off well you know it's
not you know fingers and here we go is
no magic wand yes you don't understand
to help reframe what impotence is and
means we'd be wiser to turn to some
figures from the world of culture for
the poet shall Baudelaire impotence is
an achievement of the intellect every
man should outgrow the vulgar ability to
penetrate a woman with his penis as he
gradually learns to penetrate her with
his mind for Marcel Proust impotence is
a symptom of deep politeness it Springs
from a solicitude about never wanting to
inconvenience a woman with one's
presence it's a mark of kindness and of
civilization for stardoll men who've
been impotent should be celebrated
they're going to be self-reflective
modern
just able to laugh at themselves and
probably very interesting the men who've
never known sexual Fiasco are invariably
the dull brutish and humorless members
of the race and for more Tang the
impotent man should be celebrated for
being sweetly unsure of himself and
touchingly uncertain of his prerogatives
self-doubt is at the origin of
generosity and intelligence we live in a
culture that has unfortunately come to
see hardness as the ultimate proof of
love and can't see virtues in anything
else but one shouldn't only medicalize
and stigmatize impotence we can afford
to see it as connected up with some
deeply charming and occasionally
interesting traits the partners might
come to respect and be curious about as
ever it's the job of culture to reframe
our experiences and render us a little
less lonely and persecuted
you